Traduttore: Giulia Buro'
Revisore: Silvia Fornasiero
Vi faccio una domanda
e mi aspetto sincerità.
Quanti di voi, nella loro vita,
hanno almeno fatto
una sola volta una dieta?
Alzino la mano.
Sopra si vede discretamente.
Bene. Grazie.
Quanti di voi, nella vostra vita,
avete fatto almeno cinque diete?
Siccome voglio essere buono,
stamattina non vado oltre.
E vi racconto la più grande fake news
della storia di tutti i tempi,
ovvero che le diete ipocaloriche
facciano dimagrire.
Miss e signori miei, avete perso tempo!
Se c'è una cosa
che ha dimostrato la scienza
è che la perdita di peso
non avviene mangiando meno.
E condivido con voi un altro segreto.
Oggi molti di voi
si saranno pesati sulla bilancia.
Fanno quel divertente atto
tutti i giorni per dire:
"Ma sì, perché non iniziare
bene la giornata".
E vediamo qual è il numero
che segna la nostra esistenza.
Vi siete pesati.
Fra una settimana lo rifarete.
Qualcuno di voi un po' più ossessivo,
lo rifarà anche domani.
E troverete sempre lo stesso numero.
Ma quello che voi non sapete,
quello che voi ignorate,
è che magari quello stesso medesimo numero
racconta una cosa
totalmente diversa da voi.
Ve lo dimostro.
Noi siamo fatti sostanzialmente
di quattro cose, il nostro corpo:
acqua, per lo più acqua;
per lo più muscoli,
cellule muscolari e ossa;
grasso.
L'antipatico grasso che poi, magari,
riusciremo a dire che cosa fa
ed è molto importante.
E le cellule.
Noi possiamo pesare oggi 70 chili,
possiamo pesare i medesimi 70 chili
fra una settimana,
ma l'equilibrio
tra queste quattro componenti
può essere totalmente diverso.
Qual è il messaggio?
Non fidatevi mai del numero.
Noi, anche dal punto di vista biologico,
non siamo quel numero.
Io ho avuto, come dire, la fortuna,
da un certo punto di vista,
anche la grande fatica
di occuparmi di un tema
che molti di voi conoscono,
forse conoscono in modo
un po' superficiale,
che sono i disturbi del
comportamento alimentare.
Io dirigo una struttura,
una comunità terapeutica
che cerca di curare ragazze e ragazzi
affetti da anoressia, bulimia, obesità.
E quello che ho potuto imparare
nel mio onorato servizio
è la complessità del rapporto
che noi abbiamo col cibo
e quello che rappresenta
questa complessità
dal punto di vista della nostra identità;
che noi possiamo essere
ossessionati dalla magrezza
o che noi possiamo essere
schiavi di un corpo
che in qualche modo tende
a essere in sovrappeso.
Il messaggio che dobbiamo cercare
di recuperare,
il messaggio che io ho imparato
dalle storie di ogni singola ragazza
che ho tentato di curare,
è di cosa di prezioso e di importante
si nasconde nel rapporto
tra noi e il cibo.
Vi racconto la storia di Federica.
Federica è una ragazza di 22 anni
che viene a trovarmi
perché affetta da quella che volgarmente
verrebbe definita "bulimia nervosa".
La bulimia nervosa è un tipico disturbo
del comportamento alimentare
caratterizzato dal fatto
che una ragazza ad un certo punto,
o un ragazzo, perché di questo disturbo
si ammalano anche i maschi,
ha una fame irrefrenabile,
indomabile, ingestibile,
e l'unico strumento che si ha
per calmare e spegnere questa fame
è divorare quello che si trova.
A tal punto da riempire lo stomaco
e poi essere costretti a vomitare.
Questo è il viaggio perverso
della bulimia.
Federica viene da me
e mi racconta di questa cosa
e come spesso io faccio di fronte
a ragazze che vengono con questo sintomo,
mi faccio raccontare la loro storia.
Quando Federica inizia
ad ammalarsi di bulimia?
E Federica mi racconta
una storia particolare
che vorrei condividere perché
ci insegna alcune cose.
Federica si ammala, in realtà,
all'inizio di anoressia,
perché di queste patologie, a volte,
ci sono diverse fasi di malattia.
E si ammala di anoressia
quando incontra l'uomo
con quale poi avrebbe condiviso
i suoi successivi anni
dal punto di vista sentimentale,
ma anche dal punto di vista
della quotidianità,
e scopre che anche quel ragazzo
soffre di anoressia.
Lo vede mangiare meno,
lo vede essere ossessionato dal peso,
lo vede essere concentrato
sulla sua immagine corporea.
E anche lei inizia a mangiare meno.
Inizia a pensare che forse
quella modalità di attenzione
che quella persona amata ha
nei confronti di se stesso
è una modalità per prendersi cura di sé.
E inizia così
il disturbo alimentare di Federica.
Un disturbo inizialmente caratterizzato
dalla paura di mangiare.
"Mangio meno, mangio meno,
mangio meno,
devo pesare meno, rifiuto,
devo essere forte io, vincere la fame".
Il soggetto anoressico lotta
e vuole vincere la propria fame.
Poi crolla,
perché nessuno di noi biologicamente
è nelle condizioni di poter digiunare
più di un certo periodo
della propria esistenza.
E dall'anoressia si entra nella bulimia.
Federica viene a incontrarmi.
Federica mi chiede aiuto perché lei
non sopporta quelle crisi di fame
e il vomito che poi tutto questo produce.
Federica troverà un luogo dove
curare tutto questo
che è il luogo della comunità.
Cosa c'è dietro il rapporto
tra noi e il cibo?
Vi porto due frasi
che per me sono state illuminanti.
Una è una frase storica.
Quella del filosofo materialista
Feuerbach, che dice:
"Noi siamo ciò che mangiamo".
Feuerbach dice questa frase,
la scrive in una introduzione
al primo libro di nutrizione umana
e lo dice perché critica
la filosofia idealistica e dice:
"Signori miei, iniziate a capire
che noi siamo mammiferi,
siamo esseri biologici in virtù
di quello che mangiamo.
Noi pensiamo determinate cose
anche in virtù di quello che mangiamo."
E questo è fondamentale.
Il mangiare, l'intestino,
la pancia condiziona la nostra mente.
Questo non dobbiamo mai dimenticarlo.
Poi c'è questa altra bellissima frase
di Jacques Derrida.
Un filoso più recente,
rispetto a Feuerback, che dice:
"Il cibo è metonimia dell'introiezione".
Cosa ci spiega questa frase?
Vi siete mai domandati come noi,
esseri umani appena nati,
iniziamo a conoscere il mondo?
Qual è il nostro
primo organo propriocettivo,
enterocettivo, che ci permette
di conoscere ciò che non siamo noi?
È la bocca.
Noi iniziamo a conoscere i colori,
le consistenze, i sapori
attraverso la bocca.
È attraverso l'oralità
che impariamo a conoscere il mondo.
La conoscenza inizia dalla bocca.
Non dimenticate mai questo principio.
Qual è la malattia del nostro secolo?
Perché oggi in Italia, più di tre
milioni e mezzo di persone soffrono
del disturbo del comportamento alimentare?
Perché in Italia il 40% della popolazione
è in sovrappeso o è obeso?
Perché noi siamo malati
di una malattia che si chiama,
che io ho definito,
ipertrofia dell'immagine.
Vi ho portato una bellissima opera d'arte:
Velazquez, Las Meninas.
É un quadro della seconda metà del '600.
Perché è particolare questo quadro?
Perché Velazquez fa una cosa divertente.
Inquadra l'infante Margherita,
che è la figlia di Filippo IV
e Marianna D'Austria,
ma in realtà se voi vedete
sul fondo del quadro,
e chiunque si metta nel punto di fuga
di questa bellissima opera d'arte,
può notare uno specchio dove sono presenti
il re Filippo IV e la regina Marianna.
Quando voi vi mettete
di fronte allo specchio,
tutti i giorni cercate di rendere
la vostra immagine un ideale,
di costruire un ideale di voi
che è diverso da quello che siete.
Questa è la malattia di questo secolo.
Essere schiavi di un'immagine
che diventa totalmente la vostra identità.
Le ragazze che soffrono
di anoressia, fanno questo.
Vogliono un corpo
che sostenga un'immagine
che rappresenti il loro ideale.
Pensate a quanto noi siamo bombardati
tutti i giorni dalla possibilità
di poter manomettere
l'immagine che offriamo.
Vi faccio un esempio.
Molti di voi forse lo avranno
sul loro smartphone,
ma non lo diranno per reticenza.
Quanti hanno mai utilizzato
quelle applicazioni
che vi consentono di fare un photoshop
rispetto a ciò che apparite nella foto?
Tutti quanti noi facciamo
una chirurgia estetica dell'immagine
e la facciamo con i nostri smartphone.
Noi vogliamo costruire la nostra vita
attraverso la nostra immagine.
Ma il cibo non è solo qualcosa
che sostiene solo la nostra mente,
la nostra vita e la conoscenza.
Vi siete mai chiesti perché
noi ci svegliamo al mattino
e facciamo colazione;
pranziamo intorno alle 12 o alle 13
a seconda delle varie
latitudini di provenienza,
e poi magari facciamo
uno spuntino a metà pomeriggio
e poi magari chiudiamo
la giornata con una cena?
Noi siamo mammiferi.
E come tutti i mammiferi dovremmo avere
il nostro comportamento alimentare
orientato dalle nostre
esigenze biologiche.
Si abbassa la glicemia, cerchiamo cibo.
Abbiamo freddo, cerchiamo cibi più grassi.
É estate, cerchiamo i cereali.
No.
La nostra alimentazione è un'alimentazione
assolutamente indipendente
da quello che è il nostro
fabbisogno biologico.
Benedetto da Norcia, quello famoso
delle regole: "Ora et labora",
è colui che ha stabilito i tempi
attraverso i quali
noi occidentali mangiamo.
Quando mangiamo, mentre mangiamo,
noi confermiamo l'ordine sociale
al quale apparteniamo.
Noi confermiamo delle regole di comunità.
E questo è interessante ribadirlo.
Freud quando parla di come il rapporto
tra noi essere umani si struttura,
e parte sempre da un rapporto
di dipendenza,
parla dell'allattamento.
Qual è l'altra particolarità
del mammifero umano?
Il mammifero umano nasce
ed è assolutamente alla mercé dell'altro,
non è capace di procacciarsi
il cibo da solo.
Qualsiasi altro mammifero, dopo tre,
quattro, cinque attimi dalla nascita
è capace di poter mangiare
quasi indipendentemente dalla madre.
Noi no.
E questo, dice Freud, fa sì che il cibo
rappresenti quell'oggetto mitologico
che fa da mediatore tra noi, la vita
e l'importanza della presenza
della figura di accudimento, della madre.
Ma il cibo è memoria.
Proust!
Vi ricordate quel bellissimo passo
in cui lui prende i biscotti,
li intinge nel tè e si ricorda
della amata nonna.
Ogni qualvolta noi mangiamo,
stimoliamo la nostra memoria,
stimoliamo i ricordi,
ci riappropriamo della nostra storia.
Federica entra in comunità
e Federica fa due cose.
Si confronta con altre ragazze
che hanno avuto quel tipo di problema,
ascolta le storie di altre ragazze
che hanno l'anoressia,
che hanno la bulimia.
Federica sente, sente, parla con l'equipe,
parla col suo psicologo,
parla col suo psichiatra,
racconta la sua storia
e a un certo punto capisce
che il problema non è il cibo.
Il suo quesito è:
"Perché io sono al mondo?"
"Perché dopo un anno e mezzo
dalla mia nascita,
mia madre e mio padre si sono lasciati?"
"Perché io ho un ricordo
di questa famiglia così conflittuale?"
Un bimbo che dovrebbe essere il frutto
dell'amore, viene al mondo,
e invece conosce solo il conflitto.
Federica capisce
che il suo disagio psichico,
la sua storia particolare viene
in qualche modo messa da parte
e il cibo diventa l'alibi
su cui proiettare il proprio malessere.
C'è questa bellissima frase,
sempre di Derrida, che dice:
"Il faut bien manger",
che può essere tradotto in tre modalità.
"Bisogna pur mangiare".
Il rapporto con il cibo è ineludibile,
il rapporto con l'altro è ineludibile,
e ciò che rappresenta il cibo
è ineludibile.
"Bisogna mangiare bene", si diceva prima:
l'atto del nutrimento è un atto di scelta.
Nel mentre noi scegliamo cosa mangiare,
compiamo un atto soggettivo
dove noi siamo autenticamente noi stessi.
"Bisogna mangia il bene".
E qui vi regalo un punto che per me
è stato fondamentale.
Qualche anno fa Obama disse
in una delle sue tante conferenze:
"Il cambiamento climatico inizia
sulla punta della vostra forchetta".
Quando si mangia,
non si mangia solo per sé,
ma nell'atto della scelta del cibo,
questa cosa incide anche
sugli equilibri del mondo.
E c'è tutto un filone oggi di ricerca
che mette in correlazione
le scelte alimentari
con l'aumento della produzione di CO2.
Che siamo mangiatori compulsivi
oppure restrittivi e controllanti,
in realtà noi quando mangiamo,
entriamo in risonanza con l'altro,
con chi è di fronte a noi,
con l'altro in carne ed ossa,
con l'altro che ci circonda.
Le scelte alimentari hanno a che fare
con le strade che noi percorriamo
ogni giorno nelle nostre città,
col mondo che viviamo,
con la natura che dobbiamo rispettare.
Ma vi lascio con un'altra
piccola provocazione.
Qual è il piatto tipico di Rovigo?
Non sento. Polenta?
Prendiamo un piatto di polenta.
Immaginate un piatto di polenta
e voi da soli seduti a tavola
che mangiate questo buon
piatto di polenta.
Ora, stessa medesima scena.
Stesso piatto di polenta.
Voi con una tavola
con gli amici del cuore,
con le persone amate,
con le persone piacevoli.
Quale delle due cene produrrà più sazietà?
Quella in cui avete mangiato da soli?
O quella in cui avete mangiato
con le persone a voi care?
La seconda.
Quando mangiate,
mangiate sempre con vi sta a cuore
o con qualcuno cui parlare
e guardare negli occhi,
perché ogni qualvolta
prenderete una forchetta,
prenderete un boccone di cibo,
state mangiando la vostra storia,
le vostre sensazioni,
la vostra conoscenza,
state mangiando la vostra vita.
Grazie.
(Applausi)